if you see 10 teachers they will show
you the technique 10 different ways
because that's who they are
what have we both got the same
technique
has anybody not got a navel don't count
don't put your hand up but I'll just
keep caring you'll be odd if you ever
but this is what you call here turn to
below your navel it is supposed to be
your Center
it doesn't matter if you have 10
different teachers
it's tomato sensory says oh since he
says
you've blend the hand
with your Center
I'll watch you and I watched everybody
and I don't see anybody doing
what I've been teaching for years been
preaching it
what you do is you'll hear it
and instead of it being
got really nice strong posture it's down
there you see
that's where basic has not been an
appeared
we make a sense is like you know
complicated when it's not complicated
it's going to go on YouTube if I say
this technique every time we're watching
you and that hand mustn't go past your
saying about what's two inches below
your navel or let's say five to seven
percent immediately what centimeters and
that's not going to change remember that
the rest of your life and you'll go
that's easy enough I've always got that
to check on and go like that I've got it
now
and yet you've been copying somebody
somewhere and it's definitely not me
and you're doing this keep excited
as you're saying
what's happening now
you've got to bring it back up
to throw them
so your enthusiasm in your excitement
has actually got you in trouble
because you haven't done the technique
you might say this is a really good
strong posture
and also about it gets a knife some
catch up from
you've only got in inspirational terms
in Aikido what you build yourself so we
Forge ourselves to become a martial
artist former human being a human being
makes errors marginalized must try not
to make others so we must program
however many times it takes and that
hits that spot every time every time
I don't have to lift it up anymore
I see different things in your feet
perhaps but I saw symptoms
he didn't say right you left up here
then you turn it over you put your sword
there
because that's adding a big
extra work so if you say you you stuffed
forever used stuff to have been
beginners if you start to like every
time I do Pokey you should no matter
what kind of dish it is if I always
stick to
foreign
because it doesn't work then
then you've got to work out what you're
doing wrong in the in the technique
the technique hasn't started from that
point that's just the blending so the
claiming is that
so at the blending dry you can perhaps
get lots of techniques you can make them
hackamasu rather nice
if I want to go down it's because my
nails down but the measurement's the
same
thank you
we'll get better the more you yeah
I've had my phone you have to try all
right
not just picking on you everybody
is too live
you don't take my word for it Go on
YouTube look at citizens you can cut the
garage
if you like
I'm sure we must have done that
somewhere
but it was 70 he said this is too much
of a berserking epic stuff doing oh my
gosh
try again